veamos si podemos encontrar alguna forma
de calcular 2.8 x 4.73 pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolverlo de hecho les daré
una pista traten de calcularlo usando
los dígitos no le hagan caso por ahora a
los puntos decimales encuentren los
dígitos que debe tener el producto y
usen la estimación para darse una idea
de dónde poner el punto decimal en el
producto para tener una respuesta
razonable vamos a resolverlo juntos
imaginemos que multiplicamos estos
dígitos sin tomar en cuenta los puntos
decimales
tendremos 473 por 28 podemos tratar de
calcular lo vamos a multiplicar todo por
el 83 por 8 es 24 7 por 8 56 2 58 y 4
por 8 es 32 más 5 es 37 ahora
multiplicamos todo por 2 y vamos a
tachar estos para que no nos confundan 3
por 2 y 6 y aquí tenemos que ser
cuidadosos
en darnos cuenta de que el 2 está en la
posición de las decenas por lo que hay
cero unidades tres por dos escenas es
igual a seis decenas 7 por 2 es 14 4 por
2 es 81 es 9 sumamos todo esto y nos
queda que 40 es 4 86 es 14 17 más 4 es
12 y 13 es 4 más 9 es 13 sabemos que la
respuesta final tendrá los dígitos 1
3244 en ese orden 1 3244 y ahora tenemos
que ver en donde colocar el punto
decimal para que esta sea una respuesta
razonable
aquí es donde nos es útil la estimación
sabemos qué 2.8 por 4 puntos 73 va a ser
aproximadamente igual a qué pues 2.8 se
acerca a 3 estimo que 2.8 estrés
y 4.73 se acerca bastante a 5 por lo que
esto se aproxima a 3 por 5 se acerca a
15 si ponemos el decimal aquí esto sería
mucho mayor a 15 lo que no es razonable
si ponemos el decimal aquí nos queda
1300 24.4 sigue siendo mucho mayor a 15
si ponemos el decimal aquí sigue siendo
mayor a 15 pero si ponemos el decimal
aquí parece que ahora sí es correcto 13
y 244 milésimas es cercano a 15 y de
hecho es el más cercano si pusiéramos el
decimal aquí tendríamos 1.324 4 que es
mucho menor a 15 pero como queremos que
esto sea aproximadamente igual a 15
definitivamente nos conviene poner el
punto decimal aquí es el cálculo más
razonable que tenemos ya que sabemos que
los dígitos son 1 3244 y esto nos ayuda
a colocar el decimal en futuros vídeos
encontraremos formas de hacer esto
sin tener que hacer estimación pero les
recuerdo que la estimación siempre será
clave si en algún momento de su vida se
les olvida algún método para multiplicar
decimales va a ser la estimación la que
les ayudará a encontrar una respuesta
razonable esto es muy importante
recuerdo haber leído una noticia hace un
par de años donde alguien hizo una
operación de valores y puso mal el punto
decimal y debido a esto esencialmente
vendió 10 veces más acciones de las que
debían venderse y se perdieron cientos
de millones de dólares así que los
decimales son importantes